I didn't think it could go work
[Music]
hi my name is Yoli and I'm a chef de
cuisine hi my name is Anna and I am a
sous chef and today we are trying to
guess the names of the MREs we're about
to taste and I think we're just gonna
bomb this right now honestly I'm a
little scared of it okay not ready all
right all right let's go
I'm scared there is bread this is uh oh
[Laughter]
Thanksgiving texturally it all tastes
exactly the same the meat I feel like
it'd be like four different options of
things like it could be salmon tuna
chicken it may be a baby look this over
here
definitely what a dark dark meat turkey
but the one you were cutting salmon yeah
this can be tuna oh my god tuna
casserole no no it tastes like chicken
yeah what is it
is it tuna it's tuna I'm gonna go with
the Nicastro yeah so the correct answer
is chicken noodles and vegetables in
sauce whoa obviously what is like a
chicken noodle soup to go it's not tuna
really my cat would love it now I go
ahead ground beef and sauce yeah it's a
chili oh oh um all right let's go
[Music]
well it's lush it's just like your
everything has no texture at all it
could be vegan yeah this one's kind of
weird like I want to keep eating it
because I think it has so much you guys
a lot of like powder essence chile
lasagna that's what I'm gonna call it
that's a great answer the name of this
entree is vegetable crumbles with pasta
and taco style sauce but a lot of tasty
vegetable crumbles they don't deserve
this you know what I'm not even gonna
smell it I'm just gonna go in ready yeah
[Music]
oh no no oh it's cold too I don't know I
would want it to be hot mmm I was in the
hospital in the food was better trying
to do something with olive oil I feel
like I feel like I taste like I don't
want to keep eating them but I know by
cattle every texture is different every
time every time yeah you guys know I'm
gonna [ __ ] it up to go are you ready to
guess yeah spinach artichoke pasta in a
cream sauce yeah okay it's a fettuccine
I'm very confident about this one the
name of this one is creamy spinach
fettuccine yeah let's go we're getting
better at this yeah the last one please
ready yeah all the food looks like it's
been chewed already all this is gonna be
this one this has to be a potato mm-hmm
that's pretty hard oh no no it's a
chestnut is it is it a choices oh hey
guess what it's not a potato pretend to
eat it just eat it I mean though they
don't have to be the same color yeah I
know did we keep on complaining I know
we do that because it's like weird it
has to be some like kung pao chicken
Asian style yeah stir fry mm-hmm of
every brown thing yeah it was Asian
style beef strips with vegetables nice
oh man they could have put something
chives in here or something yeah they're
gonna put tribes in the middle of a war
man they all they all were pretty bad
god bless the people that eat these yeah
I can't imagine eating this yeah on a
daily basis thank you for everything you
do
god bless you and just come and find us
and we'll make some food military we
will you're coming we're coming
[Music]
you